[Musique]
la crise de lakovic 19 qui sévit depuis
quelques semaines frappe
particulièrement les fromagers artisans
du québec dans le climat d'incertitude
financière actuelle les ventes de
fromages fins québécois enregistre une
forte baisse pour garder la tête hors de
l'eau
les artisans doivent faire preuve de
beaucoup d'imagination
[Musique]
à la fromagerie du terroir de
bellechasse le printemps marque
habituellement le retour en force des
touristes mais c'est tranquille à la
boutique du jamais vu pour cette
entreprise familiale
en affaires depuis une vingtaine
d'années ou en étant une région confiné
mais pour la boutique
cette semaine ça a été très difficile
aux affaires depuis le début de la
pandémie de kovy 19
la propriétaire anne marie girard n'a
pas eu le temps de souffler des employés
craintifs ont quitté le navire pour
protéger ce qui reste en poste et
rassurer les clients locaux toujours
fidèle est la mise en place une série de
mesures pour limiter les allées et
venues à la fromagerie
donc on prend pas de chance aux jeunes
donc les gens ont un accès restreint à
la boutique puis
si nous qui va chercher les produits
pour eux c'est primordial si on veut se
donner des chances que le maximum de nos
entreprises passent au travers ce
important d'acheter chez nous au québec
ce qu'ils sont vos si les meubles c'est
que l'appel à l'achat local lancé par le
premier ministre françois legault a été
entendu on a vraiment des nouveaux
visages parfois qui vient d'autriche ont
t ils ont entendu h au local on vient on
veux vous encourager
on nous oublie
[Musique]
les gens sont derrière nous malgré ses
encouragements
la production est en baisse de 20% la
fromagerie la petite entreprise se
spécialise dans la fabrication de
cheddar et les ventes au détail tourne
au ralenti loncin une petite reprise
tranquille et iodée
les actions qui ont été faites par
certaines maniant les districts pour
essayer de supporter justement les
petites fromageries artisanales du
québec pour stimuler les ventes
la femme d'affaires songe maintenant
offrir un service de livraison
selon elle il faut t'y novaes pour
survivre à la tempête
on est quand même puis on est ici la
moindre vision d'entreprise
dans une situation pareille ça c'est
clair
[Musique]
à la fromagerie du presbytère c'est le
branle bas de combat dans l'arrière
boutique
les employés des coupes en bal des
fromages et remplissent les sacs et les
boîtes de livraison pourtant aux
premiers jours de la crise les ventes
ont chuté de 90% boutiques spécialisées
hôtels restaurants
détaillant le marché s'est effondré
soudas n'a pu que 0 jean maureille son
équipe se sont rapidement mis en mode
solution en offrant la vente de fromages
en ligne pensez-y bouaké world nomads
ocha il a comparé cette semaine et c'est
loin d'être suffisant pour écouler les
inventaires afin de limiter davantage
les pertes et de ne pas se retrouver
avec des surplus le fromager en repenser
toute sa stratégie de production
mais là on peut pas se mettre à
accumuler des profs mal si surplus faut
arrêter les fromages qui ont une courte
durée de vie nous en avons arrêté pour
dire cela pour me diriger la production
vers n'est pas de faire et pas des
fromages de garde
dans l'église du village transformée en
salle d'affinage
le robot baptisé pattes ne chôme pas il
soigne bros et retourne les meubles de
louis d'or qui commencent à s'accumuler
l'elysée presque plein de grands
fantasmes de curés mais ça nous arrive
cette les habitent ici de voir les lys
près ce que peut être la seule la finale
risque d'être à pleine capacité dans
quelques semaines pour ne pas se
retrouver avec des surplus de lait à la
ferme le mercredi et mes temps consacré
à la production de fromage en grains une
partie du fromager donner à des
personnes âgées de la région confinés à
l'intérieur et jean morin livre lui même
une partie de la cargaison au personnel
de l'hôpital d'arthabaska des anges
gardiens à qui ils espèrent ainsi offrir
un peu de réconfort
j'ai plaisir gourmand l'un des plus
importants distributeurs de fromages
fins au québec on s'affaire à charger le
camion en prévision de livraisons dans
les supermarchés plaisirs gourmets
représente 16 fromagers artisans et
distribue une centaine de produits
la cadence des livraisons est au ralenti
depuis quelques semaines
entendu à avoir le vent dans les voiles
c'était le début de l'année 2020 et là
tout d'un coup c'est un choc assez
brutale la tempête of rapide du roi
fermeture des restaurants et hôtels
réduction importante des commandes en
boutiques spécialisées et chez les
détaillants annulation d'événements
spéciaux et d'activités promotionnelles
on disait aux gens restez chez vous donc
leur les détaillants et y en a plusieurs
qui ont commencé à faire des livraisons
choses qu'il ne faisait pas on prend les
commandes au téléphone
ramassage en magasin et nous on s'est
dit c'est formidable il ya des gens qui
veulent on voyait vraiment l'esprit de
sûr vu de nos détaillants de nos
fromagers malgré les bureaux vides des
employés de l'entreprise en télétravail
en créant tout un art
une boutique éphémère de vente en ligne
dans l'entrepôt on s'affaire à répondre
aux commandes la survie de nos
fromagerie passe par la vente des
inventaires disponibles au moment où on
doit les ventes
donc c'est un énorme défi ces efforts
conjugués des détaillants du
distributeur et des fromages et ne sont
pas vains j'ai plaisirs gourmets les
ventes ont chuté de près de 40% mais
repart que lentement
je voudrais qu'on est en pleine tempête
le meilleur ciel bleu à la raison lancé
ce mouvement alors peut continuer le ya
bel avenir pour nos fromages québec les
ont produits artisans du québec parce
qu'on sent vraiment quelque chose qui se
passe
dans la bergerie de la famille migneron
de charlevoix pas de signe de la
pandémie qui frappe le québec
la saison des agnelages bat son plein la
production laitière aussi tout un
contraste avec le restaurant et la
boutique fermée aux visiteurs à la
proche du début de la saison touristique
donc la saison tous et qui soulagera le
guen est pour moi un joueur de nos amis
aussi producteur transformateur pionnier
dans l'élaboration de fromages fins au
québec les du fou on voit maintenant
leur produit phare le migneron
s'accumuler dans la salle d'affinage
dans des fromages son temps un peu plus
resterait en temps d'affinage le
migneron par exemple c'est qu'on est aux
alentours de 50 55 60 jours d'affinage
grosso modo qu'on vole pas pour
convaincre ben c'est sûr qu'on a diminué
pour les volumes de production pour être
capable justement ne pas avoir de
fromage qui vieillissent trop de
s'assurer une certaine les efforts sont
maintenant déplacer vers les fromages à
pâte ferme au niveau des tomes entre
autres le cd produits qui vont regarder
supérier tous les produits gars qu'on
appelle donc qu'ils peuvent y est passé
sous les coups d'humour les dufour ont
aussi diversifier leurs activités au
cours des dernières années ce qui aide à
passer à travers la crise
ils produisent du vin et une onde hui
élaborée à partir du lactosérum générés
par la fromagerie la production
fromagère au ralenti a rendu les
alambics plus disponible avec la
collaboration de la microbrasserie de
charlevoix
il distille une bière pour fabriquer un
assainisseurs à main distribuée dans le
réseau de la santé
ben c'est sûr que pour nous c'est une
occasion un peu de mettre l'épaule à la
roue avec un peu tout le monde pour être
capable justement de donner un petit
coup de moins société pour être capable
de sortir un à sensor mais au delà des
gestes de solidarité
les fromagers québécois en pleine
tourmente doivent gérer la décroissance
des projets de développement des
agrandissements des investissements sont
mis sur la glace
l'ampleur des pertes est encore
difficile à mesurer
au sortir de la crise ces artisans
espère plus jamais que leur fromage
auront une place de choix dans le panier
d'épicerie des consommateurs l'idée
n'est pas d'encourager c'est d'investir
dans les produits du québec c'est de
faire en sorte qu'on investit dans notre
économie on permet à nos fromagers
artisans dans leur région de continuer
d'habiter leur territoire et de faire
une différence dans la région